en este vídeo vamos a hablar un poco
sobre los receptores de membrana los
receptores de membrana son importantes
porque son las cosas que nos permiten
comunicarnos con el mundo exterior sin
receptores de membrana nuestras células
no podrían trabajar juntas y no podrían
formar el cuerpo humano tal como lo
conocemos y así un receptor de membrana
es esencialmente una proteína integral
incrustada en la membrana celular que
participa en la comunicación con el
entorno exterior y para abreviar solo
diré que es una proteína integral que se
comunica con el ambiente exterior y así
la forma en que funcionan los receptores
de membrana es que en nuestros cuerpos
hay un montón de estas células de
señalización por ahí las llamamos
moléculas de señalización extracelular
porque están fuera de nuestras células
digamos que esta área exterior es la
porción extracelular y tenemos una
molécula de señalización rosa y para
efecto de la diagramación digamos que
parece un triángulo ahora en realidad
las moléculas de señalización no parecen
triángulos las moléculas de señalización
pueden ser de una variedad de cosas
pueden ser iones o moléculas
esencialmente que se unen a otra entidad
química también las llamamos ligando un
ligando puede ser algo como un
neurotransmisor o una hormona o
moléculas de reconocimiento celular y lo
que pueden hacer es unirse a nuestros
receptores de membrana y provocar
cambios dentro de la célula voy a
dibujar los receptores de membrana en un
bonito color azul y recuerden que
decimos que son proteínas integrales y
las proteínas integrales atraviesan toda
la membrana celular digamos aquí que
tenemos nuestra proteína integral y
entonces lo que sucede es que este
ligando se unirá a nuestra proteína
integral y esta proteína integral que
aparece en nuestra membrana celular se
unirá al ligando en forma de triángulo
que tenemos así y ahora lo que tenemos
es nuestro complejo receptor ligando es
sólo una forma elegante de decir que
nuestro ligando y nuestro receptor de
membrana están unidos y una vez que esto
sucede puede decirle a la célula que
hacer esto puede explicar cosas como el
funcionamiento de las hormonas cómo
funcionan nuestros impulsos nerviosos
porque nuestras células se dividen
muerte celular también explica por qué
nuestras células a veces permiten entrar
ciertas cosas en ellas y otras no en
términos de una aplicación más amplia en
el mundo real esto es de importancia
crítica en el diseño de fármacos de
hecho un porcentaje muy grande de los
fármacos se dirige a nuestros receptores
de membrana en realidad es así como
algunos medicamentos están dirigidos a
nuestro hígado mientras que otros pueden
dirigirse a nuestro corazón y la razón
es porque diferentes células podrían
tener diferentes receptores y estos
receptores pueden unirse a cosas
distintas todo este proceso de unión y
de decirle a la célula que hacer tiene
un nombre muy especial y se llama
transducción de señales entonces este es
un proceso que llamamos transducción de
señales lo que sucede durante la
transducción de señales es que una
molécula de señalización extracelular
este es nuestro ligando se une a nuestro
receptor de membrana y estas proteínas
receptoras causan una respuesta
intracelular entonces después de la
unión habrá lo que se llama una
respuesta intracelular
ligando se unirá a la proteína y la
proteína cambiará realmente de
conformación lo que luego activará las
proteínas de señalización intracelular
las proteínas en el lado intracelular
esto activará una cascada de señales
proteicas que alterarán el
comportamiento de nuestra célula
suena realmente complicado esencialmente
la forma en que funciona es que tenemos
una señal original nuestro ligando y
esto puede ser una hormona un
neurotransmisor o algo así esta señal
original se transmite y se unirá a una
proteína luego esa proteína le dirá a
otras proteínas dentro de la célula lo
que está sucediendo y esta señal se
propaga a través de la célula haciendo
que la célula realice una función
específica
ahora notarán que en el diagrama
dibujamos una forma muy específica para
nuestro ligando dibujamos un triángulo y
elegió un triángulo porque es fácil de
dibujar pero este triángulo en realidad
encaja perfectamente en la proteína que
dibuje que tiene un espacio vacío en
forma de triángulo
es realmente muy importante cada
receptor específico el espacio vacío con
forma de triángulo solo puede unirse a
unos pocos tipos y a menudo solo a un
tipo específico de ligando por lo tanto
solo puede unirse a ese ligando
específico con forma de triángulo rosa
los receptores de membrana permiten que
nuestro cuerpo y nuestras células
transfieran información y pueden ser muy
muy específicos al respecto esto es
importante porque cuando nuestro cuerpo
libera una hormona estará flotando en
todo nuestro torrente sanguíneo como
saben nuestro páncreas que la hormona
está destinada a él y cómo es que
nuestras células cardíacas no reaccionan
a la hormona y esta es la razón los
receptores de membrana tienen una
preferencia muy específica para ciertos
tipos específicos de ligandos esto es lo
que nosotros llamamos modelo de
cerradura y llave podemos imaginar
nuestro ligando como la llave y nuestra
proteína receptora como una cerradura
nuestra proteína receptora como
cerradura necesita un tipo de llave muy
específico para abrirla entonces de la
misma forma en que nuestro llavero
podríamos tener una
para nuestro buzón y una llave para
nuestra puerta principal y tal vez una
llave de nuestro escritorio
cada una de estas llaves hace algo
diferente y abre una cerradura diferente
y es así cómo funcionan nuestras células
ahora solo quiero hacer notar que este
es un modelo un poco anticuado nuestro
modelo actualizado es en realidad lo que
llamamos ajuste inducido y estos dos
conceptos son muy similares pero en
lugar de decir que los ligandos y los
receptores de membrana tienen una forma
muy muy específica el ajuste inducido
aporta un poco más de flexibilidad y
dice que los ligandos y los receptores
de membrana a veces pueden cambiar sus
conformación es algo así como que la
masa puede ser un poco blanda para que
puedan acoplarse en general todavía se
están descubriendo un montón de nuevos
receptores de membrana hasta donde
sabemos podemos agrupar los receptores
de membrana en tres grandes grupos el
primer grupo lo llamamos canales iónicos
activados por ligando
el segundo grupo lo llamamos receptores
acoplados a proteínas g y por último al
tercer grupo lo llamamos receptores
ligados a enzimas ahora en resumen
básicamente tenemos receptores de
membrana realmente importantes en la
membrana celular y estas son proteínas
integrales que permiten que nuestras
células se comuniquen con el ambiente
exterior el proceso en el que funcionan
estas proteínas integrales estos
receptores de membrana es que a un
ligando que puede ser unión o una
molécula puede unirse a la proteína
integral causan un proceso que llamamos
transducción de señales y la
transducción de señales esencialmente
significa que nuestra señal original o
ligando se propaga por toda la célula a
medida que se activan diferentes
proteínas que causan una respuesta
intracelular los ligandos y los
receptores de membrana tienen un ajuste
muy específico sólo ciertos ligados
específicos pueden unirse con ciertos
receptores de membrana específicos y
llamamos a esto cerradura y llave un
nombre más actualizado para esto es
ajuste inducido en el que los ligandos y
los receptores
son un poco más flexibles algo así como
una masa aunque en realidad alteran
ligeramente sus conformación es cuando
encajan y todos los receptores de
membrana que conocemos hasta ahora se
pueden agrupar en tres grupos
principales canales iónicos activados
por ligando receptores acoplados a
proteínas y receptores ligados a enzimas